tony robbins went from leaving home at
17 working as a janitor and never
attending college to empowering over 50
million people worldwide working with
presidents and owning businesses that do
over seven billion dollars a year in
revenue here's my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
[Music]
people think they have to know how i
called the tyranny of how
like you get all excited i'm gonna do
this and then your brain goes i've never
done it before oh my god what did i say
i don't know how to do this
and they tend to focus on how to do it
and when you start with how you're
screwed
like
martin luther king had no idea how when
he did his i have a dream speech in fact
his wife was the one that pushed him
because he was uncertain right you know
the real history it's pretty interesting
but the bottom line is he gets up there
and he gives his vision of how it can be
done he talked about what needs to
happen and why
if you can figure out what you want and
why you want it and you get strong
enough reasons reasons that'll drive you
late at night it'll get you up early in
the morning and the reasons are
different some people do it for
nitty-gritty reasons jim rohn used to
say because you know some guy told him
he borrowed money from this finance
company i forget the name of hfc finance
where the hell it was
and
you know he hadn't been back since he
borrowed the money you know so they're
calling them in those days they could
harass you in ways they can't today
right they call show up and embarrass
him in front of his neighbors and so jim
rohn his first real chunk of money he
told me he made because it's like he set
this goal it was his nitty gritty reason
his reason to get rich was we could go
down and pay this thing off and he said
he went to the bank and got it all in
cash and in small bills
and he bolted into this little hfc you
know finance place and the guy who
borrowed the money was the fourth best
back and he said i walked up there i
opened i opened up this brief and i
dumped all the money oliver's desk and
small bills and i said count it it's all
there i will never be back he said he
was startled because i hadn't been there
since i borrowed the money right but but
he did it for the ingredients some
people do it for their kid
some people will do it like we almost
all do it for something more than
ourselves some people do it because they
like winning
right i know that about you
right it's like i like winning i like
being the best at what i do so i'm not
going to settle for less than that why
would i
right so you got to find your reasons
but if you know what you want and you
get a big enough why now you'll figure
out how to do it but if you start with
how
you know the small brain the fear brain
goes so [__] i don't know what they
don't know where to go i don't know what
to do 90 of time either i know what and
why and then i try some it doesn't work
i try something else not hit something
else now i speed it up
by learning from the best
so that's why you know money master game
is a perfect example
my companies you know at the time were
100 million dollar companies i had one
500 million dollar company
now we're doing seven billion
i took what i learned from these guys i
applied it not only am i investing i
applied it to my own businesses why do i
reinvent the wheel when i just learned
from the best on earth i mean somebody's
that good can tell you that little two
millimeter thing that changes everything
so my life is really about learn from
the best but i don't start with the how
i start with the what and the why and i
think that's the mistake most people
make rule number two be passionate one
of the things you have to understand
about life is
everything changes and everything ends
and that kind of sounds heavy on the
front end but it's a truth
if everything changes and everything
ends number one it should make you
appreciate what you have right now
and then my view is what's next is
always better
if i make it so it's my job to make it
so and so i think you know for me i look
at it and say
you know when you said uh genius is a
young man's game i think it's total
[__]
um i think
passion is the genesis of genius
if you've got enough passion you're
gonna find answers nobody else does but
most people run out of fuel meaning they
get tired they get exhausted they get
burned out they get
uh you know the law familiarity they're
around something so much they take it a
little bit for granted and i've managed
to see something in myself
that i found in every great leader that
i've ever respected and that is
i i value intelligence immensely but i
know really smart people can't fight
their way out of a paper bag
pragmatically right i'm sure you do too
what i see is the one common denominator
of people that are successful over a
lifetime is the sustained hunger hunger
is the number one factor rule number
three keep growing we are made to grow
if we don't grow it doesn't matter how
much money you make doesn't how many
people gave you academy awards stars on
your chart i mean i get the phone calls
from all these people who you would
think have the greatest life in the
world and then they're calling me
because it's not so great because they
haven't mastered the inner world they're
good at the outer world
but this one this one hasn't been given
enough time or energy they've been so
focused out here and they've done so
well out here not so well in here this
is the one you want to do well on you
well here you can master the outside
world too you can handle anything so for
me it really comes down to looking at it
and saying okay
if you and i are going to have an
extraordinary level of fulfillment
what's going to make me grow because
that's what's going to make me proud and
to grow you've got to face challenges
and i think the biggest problem most
people have
is the biggest problem they have is they
think they shouldn't have problems you
know it's like
problems are a sign of life problems
with what make you grow now you know i'd
rather call it a challenge i'd rather
look as a challenge and take it on as a
challenge but you and i both know i mean
i have grown so much in the last 24
months taking 105 companies some of
which were literally shut down for you
know 12 months
keeping them alive not letting go on my
employees figure a way to turn around
figuring out adapt i mean i've developed
more skill and ability to help other
people because i had to manage my own
state unbelievably so and help other
people manage their state so without the
challenge would i grow so much probably
not rule number four cultivate gratitude
your happiness will never last as long
as it's got expectation behind it
don't get me wrong i have businesses i
run them we manage them but i know that
people are going to screw up or my idea
script is different than i think they
should be and sometimes their script
will turn into something even better
right i got to give it room so what i
did was i began to realize
i made the decision it's the most
important decision i believe of your
life that i'm not going to suffer
anymore life's too short to suffer and
i'm going to live in a beautiful state
every day and the way i do it is i catch
myself and i start to get that sense of
stress
i let it go and i see the eye to go by
so your thoughts
thoughts about this person messing up
your business or not following through
if i was in a room with 10 000 people i
guarantee you 60 70 percent of the
business owners have the same thoughts
at times right i ask people all the time
tell me your most stressful thought oh
i'm worried about my children this may
happen how many people have had that
thought everybody uh i might not make it
financially well how many people
everybody my point is
it's not your thought
it's the mind not your mind when you
think it's your mind you identify with
it and it's you can't separate from
yourself
but when you realize
these thoughts been around for millions
of years
and i'm just thinking the same thought
that so many people thought before like
how many people have ever thought i'm
going to kill the son of a [__] now you
didn't do it because you didn't believe
you're really going to kill them but you
felt it you said it you were there right
so we all have thoughts
it's only the stressful thoughts we
believe that mess us up so what i try to
show people is
if you can start to realize
these thoughts have been around for
millions of years if i told you a
million you know 100 years ago that
we're gonna go to the moon and back you
called me a lunatic or crazy if i said a
hundred years ago you're gonna have a
little box like this it'll fit in your
pocket
and you can click on it and you can see
what the weather is anyplace you can
click on it and see a live person on the
other side of the earth and talk to them
by looking this box and the way it works
is invisible waves are traveling around
the earth and it pulls invisible waves
in the box you go like read between the
lines there's no way you dumb idiot it's
never going to happen
so what i want you to realize those
thoughts are in visible ways
when you turn on a tv it takes invisible
waves and depending on the channel
you're gonna see a love story or an
adventure or a drama
or a comedy or a horror
the way you use your body determines
which of those thought waves come
through you one moment you're pissed off
the next moment somebody makes you laugh
you change your body you change the
channel you change what comes through
you so what i've tried to do in this
area beautiful state is simple yeah
first identify where you're suffering
what's your favorite flavor are you a
worrier are you a pissed off person
angry what is it you do yeah second of
all decide you're gonna kill that
monster while it's little you're not
gonna wait till it's godzilla taking the
city you're gonna break the pattern
you start to feel the stress you see it
as thoughts going by and then you focus
on something to appreciate enjoy or love
appreciation love and joy destroy
suffering you can't be grateful and
angry simultaneously it's possible you
can't be worried and fearful and
grateful simultaneously so i tell people
gratitude is one of the emotions to
cultivate that will destroy the
suffering and that's what we teach
people to do also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
rule number five change your focus where
focus goes energy flows
most people are focused on what they're
afraid of and so more fear comes their
way and it's easy because we all have a
two million year old brain that's
designed to look for what's wrong to
protect so we protect ourselves to fight
it or to run for it or to freeze right
that's the way our old brain is wired
it's a two million year old brain but
that brain is never going to make you
happy you have to learn to take control
of your focus and if you focus on oh my
god it's never going to work or you
listen to somebody who tells you oh you
know kova's going to be here forever
we're never going to have any freedom
again and you focus on that you can get
really depressed as most people have
we've had 100 000 people overdose on
drugs we have more depression and more
people in a suicidal mode than we've
ever seen in the last two years because
people need a compelling future you can
deal with a tough today if you got a
compelling tomorrow and so what i help
people do is design that but once you
change your focus you'll change how you
feel focus and feeling go together rule
number six build momentum momentum is
everything right the hardest part in
life is creating momentum so when that
all happened you know i had built
something of momentum over
you know 40 years literally at that
point around the world and you know what
do you do all of a sudden when you know
suddenly they say you can't do an event
with more than 10 people and you've got
15 000 people scheduled to take over the
stadium
and you know you know what i did i went
we're going to vegas they're never going
to shut down vegas right but then they
shut down vegas i was like i know i'm
going to rent a church a mega church
from a buddy of mine in houston 15 000
people they're not going to keep costco
open and shut down the church they kept
costco up and shut down the church so i
got to the point where it's like what do
you do and when you think there's
nothing you can do that's when you can
do something when you think i don't know
what to do that's when you know what to
do if you just push yourself and so i
was like i pulled my team together i saw
a guy do like a webinar with two 52-inch
screens and i said i'll kill myself
first i said i got to create an
experience for people they need it
desperately wherever they are in the
world so literally i pulled out a tape
recorder's like okay here's what we're
going to do we're going to do 20 foot
high led screens 50 feet wide highest
resolution in the world 0.67 150 you
know 50 degree 180 degrees around me
around the back i'm going to call my
buddy eric yawn i'm going to see if
zoomed we can expand in from the little
thousand to 20 000 or 30 000 i'm going
to hire a firm to create an app so they
can shake it so it sends a signal and
you can hear reality of people clapping
because the more shake it the louder it
gets and i just started creating the
whole thing in an hour there's so much
done my my cfo says uh tony um you know
after you saw all the numbers he was
over 20 million bucks what time we're
doing she's like tony should we rent
some of this first
and i said to him i said listen of all
first of all you can't i said go do your
best not what i'm looking for i said
second of all this is going to be this
way for a while yeah and we're going to
use this to help more people and then
you know when things go back to normal
we get to go do that too and i just did
a date with destiny where i had you know
uh 10 000 people from 97 countries and
then i had 500 people in front of me
because i built the studio so that
there's 40 foot high ceilings so i could
literally lift the 20-foot screen and so
now i have a hybrid event people don't
want to come personally i'm there people
that want to be in the middle of the
night in some other country are able to
participate but all that comes from just
taking action and momentum yeah if you
build momentum you can accomplish
anything you've seen it in sports you
see a team that's dominating and then
somebody steals the ball and the
momentum changes yeah your job right now
is to create momentum and that's why i'm
building this challenge is basically to
say to you let's do a breakthrough for
you right now so you know it's real
let's get you get a real result let's
get you to shift yourself physically and
mentally and emotionally so you can
build that momentum because it takes so
much energy to rock it out of the
atmosphere it takes very little to get
out of the solar system so that momentum
i think is critical rule number seven
maintain good relationships you
mentioned you reach out to someone
you'll text someone you'll send a voice
note or a video message or maybe you're
calling them or just saying hi to them
and telling them you're acknowledging
something that they're doing well that
you appreciate
i don't think that many people do this
why is this so important
for you personally and why do you think
this would help so many people get out
of themselves and overcome anxiety and
stress if they did this even a couple of
times a week i know you do this every
day but
just a couple texts a week why was this
so valuable for people uh well number
one i love people so i love to sincerely
if you just call someone to make a
compliment and it's not sincere anybody
can feel that i don't do that you know
it's like i i pride myself on finding
the goodness in people or the skill sets
in people
and i also know that what is
acknowledged tends to grow so from
standpoint of that i want them to feel
that feeling of being appreciated i want
them to know i see what's happening
behind the camera so to speak you know
it's like
that's what matters it's not how
everybody else sees you it's how you
really are and then it also deepens
every relationship you have when you
sincerely acknowledge somebody and you
notice something other people don't
notice and so it deepens the connection
and to me
quality of life is the quality of two
things your emotions and your
relationships and you know if my
emotions are terrible my relationships
are to be terrible but if i have great
emotions and i can extend that out to
help other people then it just makes me
feel more alive so i i do it for me and
them it's a virtuous cycle rule number
eight feed your mind fundamentally the
most basic thing you got to do
especially a time like covet is you got
to every day have a couple of simple
practices one of those is every day you
got to feed your mind and when i say
fiji miami consciously seek out
something that's going to give you new
insight new inspiration new way of
looking things because otherwise today
the news follows you right it's in your
pocket and the news people are good
people but they're doing their job
what's their job make as much profit as
possible how do you get the most profit
get the most people to watch i get the
most people to watch fear
if it you know if it if it bleeds it
leads is the phrase they use in
journalism right and we've seen so much
fear built up now that most people have
lost their faith
and you can't lose it fortunately it's
just a muscle that needs to be regained
but you have to fill your mind you have
to pursue it great ideas are not going
to interrupt you they have to be pursued
and the good news is today if you get
away from just the traditional news you
can do a little podcast like boss vapes
you can go to different locations you
can get another perspective and you can
feed your mind but if you don't feed
your mind my original teacher was a guy
named jim rohn
and he used to say tony i got a question
for you
he said what if
your worst enemy puts sugar in your
coffee what's gonna happen to you when
you drink that coffee is that you're
gonna have sweet coffee he said you know
what if your family member your friend
your love by accident drops one drop of
strychnine what's going to happen when
you drink that coffee is that you're
going to be dead he goes that's right
life is sugar and strychnine so watch
your coffee like every day you've got to
stand guard at the door of your mind
especially at times like this when
there's so much fear so you feed your
mind rule number nine do more for others
just to entrepreneurs in general
uh and you're an entrepreneur wildly
successful entrepreneur and uh you work
with and are friends with many many of
the top entrepreneurs in the world what
are a few of the common attributes of
the super successful entrepreneurs that
you've seen they might not be the
obvious ones that yeah you know come to
mind well gosh you know uh i'll give you
one example because i'm just talking to
yesterday mark benny office a dear
friend of mine and he runs a company
called salesforce.com he found it mark
went to my unleash the power with an
event about 15 years ago he went to it
three times you know you know his
repetitions the mother skill he immersed
himself in it again a pro not gonna do
something average comes up to me and
introduced himself and says tony he said
you've changed my life i'm working for
oracle i'm leaving i'm starting this
company salesforce.com we're going to
change the business world and everything
so we're going to do a hundred million
dollars in business i was teasing me at
night he's gonna do seven billion this
year right and i've been on a 15-year
journey with them you know what what do
they have in common they have a sense of
something they want to serve greater
than themselves you know the only
challenge sometimes in network marketing
and i think what gives it a bad
reputation for some people is you get
people in there that really act like
they're doing it for something larger
than themselves but it really is only
them now there's nothing wrong with you
wanting to profit and be successful but
motive does matter and the most
successful entrepreneurs have a motive
that includes themselves but they want
to do something that's going to change
the world make the world different it's
like you know when you're trying to meet
your own needs you get a certain level
of insight if you're trying to meet the
needs of the
family your family and you you get a
different level of insight because life
supports whatever supports more of life
more people if you're trying to support
your community differently if you're
trying to you know have an impact on the
world it's even larger and i found in
network marketing you find a few
missionaries that are like those other
entrepreneurs that it really is their
mission they honestly do it for free and
you know they want to make money and
they do make money but if you're only
doing it for the money the unfortunate
part is um people sense that and then
they feel like it's just a transaction
as opposed to an experience of added
value it's only one way on earth
to really become wealthy and that is do
more for others than anybody else is
doing and rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
recognize and create patterns no matter
how long you live no matter what changes
in society skill number one
it's the ability to recognize patterns
you're really good at it you do it in
finance you do it in business you're not
just blowing your smoke that's why
you're successful because when you
recognize patterns it allows you to go
the second step which is use them
if you recognize financial patterns you
can do great things you recognize
patterns of business you can turn around
in your business you know that's what
i've been doing i have 105 companies now
we do seven billion dollars in business
and i have no business background but i
recognize the patterns and i studied the
billionaires that started with nothing
and said what did they do how did they
do it how they turn it around so if you
can recognize patterns and if you can
use them
you got a great advantage but then
gradually over time like you know if
you're going to play the piano you
usually play other people's music
initially and then there's a point where
you come through
now you start creating patterns
and when you start creating patterns
that's when you become a dominant force
in business and life in the marketplace
and with your children or anywhere else
when 9-1-1 happened and i'll finish with
this i was in hawaii
i was with 2 000 people from 45
countries we were translating four
languages simultaneously for a program
that i was conducting for a week
the night before was called emotional
mastery i got up had no plan for this
and i said
uh we had a list of fireworks i do crazy
fun stuff and then at the end i stopped
and i had this plan i was going to save
it i never do what i'm going to say and
all of a sudden i said when do people
really start to live
when they face death
and then what this whole thing about if
you were going to get off this island if
nine days from now you were going to die
who would you call what would you say
what did you do
one woman well that night is when 911
happened one woman had come to the
seminar and when she came there she her
previous boyfriend had been kidnapped
and murdered
her friend her new boyfriend wanted to
marry her and she said no he said if you
leave and go to the hawaii thing it's
over with her she said it's over when i
finished that night she called him and
left a message true story at the top of
the world trade center where he worked
saying honey i love you i just want you
to know i i want to marry you it was
stupid of me
she was asleep because it was 3 a.m for
us when he called her back from the top
and said honey i can't tell you what
this means
he said
i don't know how to tell you this but
you give me the greatest gift because
i'm going to die
and she played the recording for us in
the room she was on larry king later
and he said you're probably wondering
how on earth this could happen to you
twice and he said all i can say to you
is this must be god's message to you
honey from now on every day give your
all love your all don't let anything
ever stop you i really want people to
know
everything
life is always happening for you not to
you if you believe it's happening to you
of course it is you know you look for
what's wrong what's wrong is always
available but if you train yourself to
look for what's right and you find it
you won't be the person sitting on the
curb crying or feeling sorry or drugging
yourself up you'll be like i'm gonna
crush it and i'm gonna find the good in
this it's not good on the surface but it
becomes good when you do something with
it so there is always a way but it
requires a different level of energy it
requires that you have something you
want to serve more than yourself because
you're only serving yourself you don't
get a lot of insight nothing wrong with
that but but you're trying to serve your
family you're serving more of life so
life gives you more serve a community
serve humanity i'm not talking virtual
signaling [__] i'm talking about you
know what's in your heart you get a
different level of insight and a
different level of energy so you got to
find something you care about more than
yourself in the middle of covid and you
got to find a way to retool yourself to
move forward because the opportunity is
going to be there winter's not forever
the the tide will shift and you want to
be ready or ideally take advantage of
even before the tide shifts i was in my
early 20s and i developed this
incredible arsenal of tools a toolbox a
tool chest if you will of the very best
tools to create change rapidly things
that look like magic to people where i
could take somebody and i would go on a
radio show or a tv show and i would
challenge traditional psychologists and
psychiatrists and i'd say give me your
worst patient i don't care if they have
uncontrollable phobias have them come
see me i'll handle it in one hour and i
developed this idea that i was the one
hour the one stop coach the person that
can help people make any change and i
built my career by actually doing that i
got on television and radio and i took
people with lifetime phobias and turn
them around and these are all just
techniques and strategies that i didn't
develop i just kept looking for the best
and i kept synthesizing it and bringing
it forward so when i started out here i
was this guy helping people lose 30 60
90 in some cases 200 pounds or taking a
guy that was barely surviving
financially and within a couple years of
this
counseling or coaching as i started to
call it really got him to turn his
business around and literally got him
financially independent relationships
that were falling apart and i i learned
the distinctions to help couples change
and so when you start getting those
types of results that are that
measurable people started giving me
attention and the media started to come
to me and then what they wanted to know
was this what are you
you know and i thought are you a guru i
said no no no no no i'm not that you're
mr motivator like no no i i'm certainly
believing people having an inspired life
and think about it inspiration is pretty
important if you're not inspired what is
inspired it means in spirit means
there's an energy in your life if you're
not inspired about your life what do you
have nothing but
i'm really more about strategy and they
kept pushing me guru motivator what are
you you know
and i said well you know what i really
am i'm a coach
and i came up with that metaphor i mean
there's always been consultants in
business i wasn't talking about
businesses it was individuals
and i said i'm not a therapist you know
i said and i don't have a degree
people pay me because i produce
measurable results they pay me nothing
unless i do it that's how i set up my
career that's how i built my brand and i
said you know for me coaches are people
that not better than you are a coach
just has a different perspective i mean
even back in those days the best
athletes in the days the gretzky's the
michael jordans etc they all had a coach
still to this day the best have coaches
cause the coach can see what you can't
see because you're in the force they're
outside of it
and i know as an athlete i was better
than some of my coaches but they made me
better
so i said that's my job i'm a coach
because to be a coach is not better
they're they're a friend they're they're
an equal they're there for you there's
somebody who cares deeply about your
well-being but they're also incredibly
skilled to help guide you at the moment
you really need it
and so i started promoting this idea of
being a coach and
you know the sports metaphor helped some
people but the media didn't buy into it
very much but i was able to succeed
finally because i was able to keep
measuring these results i mean i would
go out and say i'll come see me for one
session i'll handle this problem or you
pay me nothing and you can check it out
for 60 days i still use that formula to
this day as many of you know with my
products and services so what was really
fascinating though was along the way i
was there's a point after years of
calling myself a coach and there's no
coaching industry nobody talking
themselves as coaches i remember at one
point i hit a point where i was about to
give it up and larry king even said to
me on on air one time you say you know
what is this you're a coach what does
that mean i was trying to explain peak
before it's coaching and strategy and so
forth and
and right about that time suddenly
coaching became the term of art and
everybody was a coach therapist started
calling themselves coaches you know uh
financial planners became coaches it
just became the term of art so it's been
a fascinating journey watching that word
come in because what i did is i helped
build that term by making it based on
real results i think this idea of loving
yourself as a cultural obsession has no
basis in reality
here's the challenge when you're born
what do you got to do to be loved
nothing because your mother's on drugs
uh natural dogs oxytocin so you look
like a lizard and she thinks you're
beautiful right you know you're fat you
[__] all over you throw up and you're
still beautiful right for a while you're
unconditionally loved and thank god we
would have survived otherwise i'm so i
love women so much i have so much
respect for women even more so going
through birth again
no man will ever fully appreciate what a
woman does or what a baby demands a
mother if you're breastfeeding and the
energy and the no sleep i mean it's just
it's amazing what women do in our lives
but the point is in the beginning you're
going to do nothing and then the
oxytocin wears off and suddenly you do
the same scream or yellow throw your
food now you get yelled at or hit or the
worst one of all you get ignored
and then fear enters your body and then
the rest of your life you're looking for
how can i get this unconditional love
and i remember in the beginning asking
myself because i studied all animals and
what the level of dependency they have
and you know human beings have the
longest period of dependency for
survival of any creature other than
other primates whales will be dependent
for a year birds for a few weeks and
boom get your ass out there and fly you
know it's a different world we have this
long dependency it's just the nature of
how we are and i thought to myself so
why
why don't we just have unconditional
love all the time and i think my answer
is because then you never grow or give
anything to life you think everything is
about you
and unfortunately there are a large
population of kids that are raised in a
generation of parents that were
helicopter parents that thought
everything should be about the child and
they wonder why they're selfish today or
why they you know don't seem to have
great relationships where you've got to
be with somebody else you're going to
put somebody else out of you that's what
love is
love is putting somebody else ahead of
yourself
loving yourself
usually comes from most human beings by
starting to have a value and just
appreciating people not because of what
they do not because of what they have
just because you feel their essence
and it's easier to do that with somebody
you love than is with yourself but when
you start doing somebody else and you're
not judging you're truly loving them
then it's much more natural because
you're already doing the loving you're
not getting it from somewhere else
someone may say something look you a
certain way as a trigger but all love is
self-love
this [__] i don't love myself if
you've ever been someone who felt loved
you loved yourself they didn't love you
they said something needed something
with their eyes and you used that as a
trigger to release love inside of you
but
loving yourself every moment all the
time is not the secret to success having
appreciation for yourself is different
than constantly loving now in the bible
it says love thy neighbor as thyself so
i think it's a worthy goal and it's
useful but most people are obsessed with
it and i think get on about living a
life that's meaningful and you'll love
yourself as long as you focus on you
you're not going to love you
because the human brain is always
looking for what's wrong what to protect
what needs to be changed it's a survival
instinct and so it's looking for things
to fight or flight or try to freeze or
pretend you're not there about yourself
but when you're in a bit of service when
you're trying to serve something more
than yourself that's when the higher
part of your consciousness is there
that's when your heart is flowing and
when you're doing that you're not
thinking about you and therefore you
feel love and i can tell you my own
experience
i've i don't have to no one else have to
earn love with me but my strategy has
been i got to earn my own love right i
got to be worthy of my own love i don't
do that somebody else how do you do that
well by helping millions of people for
you know 44 years now i'm finding the
stage well yeah i [__] love myself
i'm not there i enjoy myself or
appreciate it but along the way
i've always earned it now i don't think
that's necessarily healthy or not but i
like what it's done with me if i know
people that just think they're god's
gift to creation and they don't add
anybody to any other human being they're
[__] to be around they love themself
so i just i would challenge that whole
belief system i'd say it's appreciating
yourself
it's loving the people around you and
the more you can unconditionally love
others the more you'll unconditionally
have yourself but trying to start with
yourself when you're not doing with
others forget it it'll never happen if
you haven't made a decision about what
you're going to do in your life you have
actually made a decision it was a
decision in action where does that
decision take people
well i think um it happens at different
stages it's not like you have to have
this one mission a lot of people are
paralyzed i don't know my purpose well
your purpose is to enjoy your life to
grow and to give like
everyone has different ways but we all
compare it sometimes is it enough is it
strong enough is it big enough what i
found in my life is do what's in front
of you with all your vigor all your
passion give the most you can focus on
giving not trying to receive and you'll
receive more than you could ever imagine
but the person is always trying to get
nobody wants to deal with that person
nobody wants to be around them the
secret to living is giving it's what
makes you feel alive because you're no
longer in scarcity you're no longer
trying to get and no one wants to be
around them but you want to be around
yourself in that state how do you get
out of it it's just a habit it's just
like let me find every day one person to
start my day that i can sincerely
compliment no bs find something great
about them or someone i could help who's
in a worse case than i am could be
something very little but when you get
in those habits then all of a sudden
life is you know like i wake every day
my whole thing before i came here if i
do anything is like god use me you know
it's like i want to be a blessing in the
life of anybody i meet in some way
sometimes that blessing is i can take a
picture for them and they're excited
sometimes i can do an intervention
sometimes i can find a seminar sometimes
i can just love on them sometimes asking
a great question but if we're all
focused on being a blessing in each
other's lives then our life is filled
with blessings because we're not trying
to get all the love you want from others
if you feel inside yourself you'll be
expressing it to others and every time
you express it you feel alive inside
otherwise people tell you they love you
all day long and you can go yeah yeah
they don't really love me you know i
know lots of celebrities who started out
wanting so much love so they become
successful and unique so they get all
this adoration and they don't like their
lives now because they don't think it's
sincere i said you know your focus is if
you're celebrity why don't you use your
platform to serve in some way outside
what you do not attack but surf if you
do that you're gonna have a rich life i
remember turning 40
and i was really really unhappy i was
like jesus i've not done enough i've not
helped enough people i know tens of
millions of people at that point already
all over the earth in 100 plus countries
at that point but it was still kind of
stuck in my head so i would earn the
love by over delivering change
somebody's life like i don't get it
because somebody says oh i love you tony
i mean i appreciate that or oh you're
the greatest it's got to be my standard
my standard's higher than their standard
for me right so when i get up and
someone's going to kill themself and
it's they're suicidal and boom turn
around they're no longer not going to
kill themselves but they're transformed
their life is there you know that's when
i go okay you know now we've hit the
center of what i'm made for now you know
i deserve to feel this euphoric feeling
within myself and appreciation and even
then i still know it's god coming
through me i don't have the delusion
it's just me
but
i think sometime after 40 i finally saw
the stupidity of it i accumulated enough
that i looked at life with fresh eyes
and i could say by time i turned 60 a
year ago i noticed it was interesting
because my birthday i didn't have an
ounce of it i was just like
you know how could i at this stage of my
life when i've had the privilege of
serving so many humans in so many
contexts you know from turning around
you know guys are going to kill
themselves with ptsd to helping kids
turn around to getting kids off cocaine
or adults to you know help people build
multi-billion dollar businesses from
nothing and when i've lived this long i
can't go by without hearing half a dozen
stories a day or dozen stories a day
from people telling me how something i
did change their life so it's not that
i'm so smart now it's just i've stacked
it by the way though stacking is the way
you can do things
most of us stack the negative
if you are really angry it's not usually
because it's just the moment
it's that it happened again you know
it's like if you've ever lost it or
overreacted to your kid or to a friend
or a business or even within yourself
it's because it happened again we hit
this one two three many point and then
our nervous system overreacts but what
i've learned is you can stack the good
and but for example if you're if you go
into a state of really strong anger for
more than five minutes your immune
system is suppressed between an hour and
a half to two hours that's a
physiological fact
but no one had done any study i started
stacking good like okay let me stack a
dozen great memories feel them see them
experience them and i felt this
biochemical change that didn't just last
a half hour an hour or ten minutes it
went on for a day or two and so i think
uh i've learned to stack the good so
just having the experience is not enough
you got to stack the good to be able to
appreciate it but i i think just come
back to the main point here from my
perspective which could be completely
just my perspective so i want to point
that out
i think the more
you find unconditional love for others
the easier it is to find in yourself
and i think the focus is serving and
loving and that's what will get you the
point where you start doing it but if
you want to speed it up stack all the
good you've done you'll feel great about
yourself there's so many things you know
people's relationships are complex right
because you're dealing with another
species even if you're gay in order to
have a a relationship you need opposite
energies max male and female energies
even if it's in the same gender and so
relationships are a huge source of
challenge for people because it's where
you get the greatest joy to get the
greatest pain um i think in business
most people get into business we all
know the stats 50 of businesses are gone
the first year 96 percent are gone in
ten years four out of 100 make it that
doesn't mean they're profitable so
there's different issues that you deal
with there people's bodies because of
the way we have commercialized food
makes almost everybody about 70 of
americans are overweight i mean it's the
fast country in the history of the world
and the rest of the world's mirroring us
so i deal with so many different issues
it really depends on the person people
come to me
usually at extremes they're either the
best in the world of what they do and
they're doing well and they just they're
the best because they're always looking
for that little step that little thing i
can do that makes me better better
better and takes me to a different
destiny
or it's somebody facing a challenge you
know their thing a financial challenge a
business challenge an emotional
challenge a relationship challenge with
their kids or they have a birthday with
a zero on it so they're reevaluating
their life so i i get people who have
found a hunger they're hungry because
it's not how they want it or they're
hungry because that's their nature
people are not hungry i don't really
deal with because they pretty much
accept where things are and so and so
when i wish for them what i pray for
them is they find something to inspire
them more than themselves or their wagon
wheel comes down their rut you know they
get enough pain that they start
searching and i don't care how smart you
are strong or how rich you are how
famous you are
life is gonna humble you you know like
life's gonna take you to your knees the
real question is what are you gonna do
when that happens and so for me it's
really like what this challenge is about
it's like a comeback challenge the
greatest story again what is the
greatest story of mankind what's the
story we all love in books and movies
it's a comeback it's somebody gets taken
to their knees unfairly unjustly
whatever or their own ego takes them
there and then instead of giving up they
get up they get knocked down they get up
yet and then eventually they only get up
and they don't get to where they were
get them better than they were michael
gerber the guy that wrote the e-myth you
know talks about why so many businesses
young businesses fail and one of these
things he says is most people
are not really entrepreneurs but they
think that's what they should be
they think that's the sexy thing that's
the most attractive thing that's the
best answer
and what i say to you is you got to
separate the vehicle
from the outcome
what is it that's going to truly fulfill
you what is it that's going to give you
that extraordinary life what's going to
make things magnificent on your terms
not somebody else's terms not your
father your mother your background what
is that really separate the vehicle
because there's many ways to get that
vehicle but i'm saying sometimes you got
to re-evaluate what's going to really
make you fulfill
what is your gift
are you an artist are you the talent can
produce something no one else produces
as a skill or a product or a service or
some impact
are you incredibly good at management
you really know how to manage or lead
people
are you an extraordinary entrepreneur
that has can take that gigantic gut load
of risk
and can create the vision and attract
the talent that you need and the
managers and leaders you may have all
three abilities
but which one really fulfills you the
most
is going to be the critical question
because we tend to want to do them all
especially room like this because you're
all over achievers right me too
and you say i can do all these yes you
can
but what will it do to your quality of
life
see again the secret's going to be this
what is an extraordinary life on your
terms today ultimately if you're going
to have lasting change in anything
you're really talking about just raising
your standards i mean i always tell
people if you want to know how to change
your life and give it to you in three
words boring as it sounds raise your
standards
and what does that mean cornies and
sounds raise your standards i'll thank
you for the breakthrough thought tony
i'm glad i wasted my time watching this
little email with you but think about it
lasting change is different than a goal
you don't always get your goals but you
always get your standards maybe it'll
help you is to think about it this way i
try to explain standards to people with
a different set of words
think of it as
everybody in life gets their musts
they don't get their shoulds
right think about it
most people have a list of shits don't
they don't you have a list of the shirts
things you should do you should follow
through on i i should lose some weight i
should work out more i should make more
calls i should respond more rapidly to
my email whatever you know i should get
into the office earlier i should be you
know more confident whatever your should
list is people love to have their should
list be met but it's kind of like new
year's resolutions
if it does it's really exciting but if
it doesn't which is most the time it's a
little disappointing but you kind of
know it's not going to happen
but when you decide something is a must
for you an absolute must when you cut
off any possible you say i'm going to
find the way i'm going to make the way
human beings when they resolve things
when they make a real resolution inside
themselves which is they raise the
standard and they make it a must they
find the way
think about in your own life
haven't you had some area of your life
where you raise your standard and your
life has never been the same
maybe at one time in your life you
smoked cigarettes or you did something
and you did it for years and you kept
trying to change it trying to change it
and kept telling yourself i should and
then one day something happened
something just clicked you over
something took you over that kind of
tipping point
and inside yourself you said no more
it was a very very different experience
wasn't it something inside of you
shifted and what was a should became a
must and you've never gone back
is there an area like that in your life
you can think of again do you ever smoke
cigarettes did you ever eat a certain
way drink a certain form of alcohol and
then finally say no more and you just
don't go back and notice this
it doesn't really take any willpower
anymore
because somewhere when we make this
click we make something a must
we attach ourselves to it
it becomes part of our identity
one thing i've learned in the last gosh
33 years of working with people from now
over 100 countries 4 million people is
human beings absolutely follow through
on who they believe they are
if you say it said to me well i'm really
going to work hard to stop smoking
but you know i've been a smoker my whole
life and i'm you know i am a smoker
i know your days are numbered you're
going to be back smoking cigarettes
again because we all act consistent with
who we believe we are
i tell people the strongest force
in the whole human personality is this
need to stay consistent with how we
define ourselves
if you define yourself as somebody who
is really conservative you're not going
to be crazy and act nuts unless you're
really drunk or something and then you
can say it's the alcohol when it's
really just you
finally getting permission to be
yourself the alcohol is your excuse
if you're a really crazy person you act
crazy outrageous playful you don't act
conservative because that's not who you
are
very often people say well i can't do
that i'm not that kind of person and i
always say to people really
when did you define yourself
i mean really how many years ago did you
come up with what you could and couldn't
do in your life
how many years ago
most people if they really look at how
they're living their life today it's
based on a set of standards a set of
beliefs that they made choices about 10
20 30 or more years ago
i mean very often we made decisions in
our youth or very young about what to
believe about what we were capable of
about who we are as a person and that
becomes the glass ceiling if you will
that controls us
there's a corny metaphor but it's true i
remember one time i was with my family
at the circus and there was a person
there and they had this big giant
elephant and you look at this elephant
and they take this little rope put
around the elephant's neck and they
drive the stake into the ground
and i mean you look at this and you know
that elephant could rip down the entire
tent with almost no effort and yet the
elephant doesn't struggle doesn't try
why because the elephant's conditioned
and they take that elephant condition
the elephant when it's a baby elephant
that's how they train him when it's a
little baby elephant and it doesn't have
the power yet they put a big rope around
it and they drive this huge stake in the
ground and the elephant fights and
fights and fights and one day finally
that elephant decides i'm not capable of
pulling this out
and once that becomes the definition of
an identity of anyone an elephant in
this case
they don't even try anymore it's just
who i am that's how it is that's just
the way it is in my life i'd like to ask
you to take a look at any place you've
got a limitation ask yourself when did i
decide to accept that limitation and you
may not even see it as a limitation you
might see it as just that's who i am
but so often in our lives we've adapted
to
be a certain way so that we don't fail
or so that people will like us or
respect us but it's not necessarily who
we are
joy comes when you're spontaneous it's
really hard to be truly happy when
you're not being yourself and most of us
have no clue who we are and so a big
part of my work if you've ever been to
an event you know is to get people to do
things spontaneously without thinking
because that's when the real you shows
up that's when the energy comes alive
and when you do that when you start to
connect your true nature
suddenly there's energy available for
you to set a higher standard for what
you want in your life that's what this
is really all about and when i talk
about standards when i talk about you
know shoulds versus musts think about
your own life
i know there have been areas in your
life where some point in time you just
shifted and you raised the standard in
your life changed
because
whatever people have their identity
attached to
they live
we live who we believe we are that's
just how it works it's just kind of like
i give an example
look at your physical body your physical
body today is an absolute reflection of
only one thing not your goals
not your desires but your standards
the identity you have for yourself if
your standard is you're an athlete
then there's a certain amount of
strength a muscle tone and energy that's
available in your body on a regular
basis because that's who you are and so
you do whatever is necessary to maintain
that identity again the strongest force
and the human personalities this need to
stay consistent with how we define
ourselves
because
if you don't know who you are you would
know how to act
once you lock in on that identity your
brain finds a way to keep you there if
you say uh you know man i'm overweight
i've always been overweight i'm big
boned and that's the story you got then
you're gonna always find a way to get
back there that's your settling point
that's your identity that's where things
lock in if you see somebody who's in
really great shape you ask them do you
work out you know the answer yes how
often and they'll tell you three times
four times five times a week whatever in
a seminar last people who here works out
at least five days a week and i'm stand
up and you look around that room
and you know that they work out five
times a week because you can see their
body you don't just get a result without
some kind of action without some form of
ritual ritual meaning actions you do
consistently
now do you think those people that are
out there working out five days a week
do they have more time than you do
or i have or anybody else of course not
is their life less busy of course not
it's just a must for them they must work
out that way and they've made that turn
in their life changed so i'm not saying
you have to work out five days a week
i'm just saying whatever you really want
once don't get met consistently
standards do
whatever you identify this is who i am
and so it's not so much about changing
your identity is there's expanding it
you know deciding that you know instead
of your goals to lose
10 pounds which is not compelling what
if your vision was to get back to my
fighting weight you know this this year
this month this next 90 days i'm going
to transform my body i'm going to take
on a new challenge i'm going to find
some technique or strategy there's a
million of them that can reframe myself
or i'm going to feel younger stronger
more vibrant than ever before here's my
reasons because i want the energy to
really make my life work because it's
tough out there and i want to be
stronger than i've ever been before i
want to go in front of the mirror and if
i'm naked not you know want to laugh i
will look there and take a good look and
go yeah
i'm proud of whatever i see there
whatever it takes something's going to
make you laugh smile something that's
going to tease yourself but something's
going to move you to another level if
you identify yourself in a new way and
you own that every day and that becomes
the standard how you live you'll find
the way to make that standard real
money is the same way think about it
doesn't matter what's happening quote
unquote in the marketplace
people that make money find a way to
make money no matter what don't they
i mean
most people's standard is to pay their
bills
so that's what most people find a way to
do even when economic times get tough
most people if that's their absolute
standard they find a way
some people's standard is pay their
bills most of the time
and so most of the time they do
some people's standard is not just to
pay their bills but to take care of
their family and maybe even some of
their friends
and they find a way in fact you know
some people may be in a family where
they don't have enough money they barely
have money to pay their bills
they work their guts out and then
somebody their mother their father
somebody else their sister gets ill
and there's not enough money to take
care of it nobody else has money in the
family they don't either but they find a
way to get that money to take care of
their mother or father don't they
and pay their bills
they never could do it before why the
situation made them raise their own
standard and not everybody does that
somebody else in the family might have
money and still not take care of their
mother
it all comes down to the inner game my
friends
changing your life is a change in the
inner game
the outside world you can't control but
you have absolute control over this one
if you learn the dynamics of what shapes
you
and identity is one of those simple
clear
fundamental basics that if you start
start to shift it everything else will
shift in your life as well some people
by the way have to have more than enough
money to do what they want when they
want where they want with whomever they
want contribute the way they want
if that's their must they find a way i
know that sounds overly simplistic
but it's true
you know somebody once said you can take
all the money in the world out of the
hands of everybody out of all the
wealthy people in the world who are
really successful give it to other
people it wouldn't take too long those
people have it back in their hands it's
not because they're manipulatives
because they have a standard some are
manipulated don't get me wrong but they
got a standard of what they're going to
find a way to make happen i'm just
simply saying to you take those three
magic words and live them raise your
standard why is lebron james who he is
it's not because he's lucky in other
words saying you know he's lucky
he may have certain physical facts or
michael jordan i remember i interviewed
him years ago
and i said what makes you the best in
the world is it skill is it talent is it
ability is it backward is it training
and he was so awesome he said tony i can
tell you the truth and it won't sound
like hyperbole or false modesty he said
i didn't even make the high school
basketball team my sophomore year i was
cut
he said what it is is every day i demand
more for myself than anybody else could
possibly expect i don't compete with
other people i compete with what i'm
capable of and there's just like that
kind of standard is inspiring what is
the one thing that you want people to
understand about control when they feel
out of control they feel they don't
understand the stock market like what's
the one message you wanna you want
people to take home around control i
think it's uh that you have to become an
owner and not just a consumer you have
to take a percentage of what you earn as
simplistic as it sounds and automate it
so it comes off the top of what you earn
uh there's a gentleman used work for ups
names theodore and theodore robinson was
this guy who never made more than 14 000
a year and yet he retired with 70
million dollars and gave away 35 million
was alive how did he do it he became an
owner his best friend said to him listen
to me the most important thing in your
life is we're going to put a wealth tax
on you because a wealth tax i think 14
000 a year he goes we're gonna make you
wealthy with this tax it's not a
government taxes tax for yourself so
we're gonna take twenty percent of what
you earn and put in an investment
account let it build up he said i can't
afford that he goes once it's automated
you won't notice
that's all he did that made him 70
million so it's like people have to
understand that no matter how good you
are in business we all need a second
business with no employees and it takes
very little time something that once you
do your homework should take you you
know 15 minutes to an hour twice a year
to rebalance perhaps but outside of that
that's what this is this is setting up a
business that will make you do well when
i was um how did i was 20
24 years old 25 years old i worked with
a man named ken blanchard who wrote
those one-minute manager books you
probably remember him evan yeah
really great guy and he i helped him
take five strokes off his golf game and
that made me god to him so
and then he said i want to return the
favor and he goes the best advice i got
growing my business was i was about to
come out with my first book
and he said a friend of mine who's very
wealthy said do not put that money in
your company let the leads go to your
company do not let the profits go and do
not spend those profits put that in a
separate account that nothing ever
touches because your business will eat
whatever resources you have what a
growing business does that and he said
tony i put that aside and during the
tough times that's what made me safe
well i did the same thing with that in
my original infomercials that alone made
me a wealthy man so when tough times
came i could withstand it so i see so
many business owners go yeah but i have
control of my business [__] you have
influence over your business yes you
have more influence but there are better
entrepreneurs than you perhaps out there
as well or businesses that get greater
valuations in your business will and so
your ability to grow you want to grow
your own business i always tell people
you want to build two businesses the
business you're in in the business
you're becoming and then you want to
have the business that you're in and
becoming an investment business it's
really simple once you set it up and i
think everybody's got to do that if they
really want to have financial freedom
because look the marketplace changes
competition changes ibm was the head of
the pack forever and then some little
kid from microsoft comes along and buys
ms-dos for fifty thousand dollars and
then leases it to them and makes himself
three billion on that little move alone
he didn't even write their software
right you know he's doing great and all
of a sudden you know this little company
comes along a couple of guys at stanford
called google you know and apple comes
along so there's always disruption and
the disruption can be competition it can
be new technology it could be a change
in the culture so even if you do
everything right you could lose i want
people to have a back-up plan this is
the back-up plan breakdowns it's
certainly not something i experienced
but it's not because i'm so talented or
so brilliant or so fearless it's just
you're like an athlete you're an athlete
yeah you're in shape yeah right you're
not gonna have a reaction in your body
like somebody who doesn't take care of
themselves right so you know i believe i
don't believe in emotional intelligence
i think it's useful but i'm more
interested in emotional fitness because
intelligence is a capability fitness is
a state of readiness interesting if you
are fit you can take that demand right
now you can deal with it you can deal
with that physical stress that emotional
stress same thing's true with
psychological fitness emotional fitness
right so i'm pretty fit and part of that
is not because i'm so smart part of this
i i've taught this for decades i
remember had a woman who came on my
seminars in um in her i don't know early
80s probably and she would run in this
room five ten thousand people i think
was you know she had a couple of ten
thousand person events and she would get
in this front row fighter way through
there and she'd jump and go for it at
one break she came up to signing a book
for her and she says she goes mr ramsay
i've seen you at like eight of these
i've seen you like when you're really i
know i can hear your voice you're
hurting or you haven't slept and she
goes you always seem to be so up all the
time how come you're so up and i said
well probably i attend all these
seminars yeah so i'm teaching it so
there's a fitness of that there's also
you know i've i've buried three fathers
and one mother and you know that affects
your life i've you know i've had a
physician look me in the eye and say you
have a tumor in your brain wow and so
i've had those moments that
when you've had extreme stress
and you push your way through it you
build psychological muscle it's like it
takes a lot to knock me off you know in
the early days we didn't have fifty
thousand dollars keep the doors open how
do we do it then i had you know
graduated to five million then i
graduated to uh a partner that
mine who kind of didn't do things well
and i ended up owning a hundred million
dollars because i had to take on his
debts 100 million dollars and but when
you do all that stuff you know now my
companies do five billion you know a
year so
uh
you you keep expanding what i would call
really the circle of your the threshold
of your influence sure you know
everybody has a threshold of control and
if you get beyond it you kind of freak
out so
it takes a little bit more i don't know
i guess you don't have breakdowns it's
not a breakdown do i get pissed off or
get frustrated or tired yeah but break
down honestly no what would you tell the
startup entrepreneur who maybe is just
getting started or maybe still has a
full-time job and it feels like every
dollar that they're making they're just
trying to build their business at the
moment they haven't cashed out yet
should they be investing into their
business should they still be saving
someone put into the market what would
you tell that person i think you have to
put something outside your business
because what's the number one rule of
investing that even idiots understand
don't pull all your eggs in one basket
right and what did 90 of entrepreneurs
do because of the illusion of control
they go i'm going to put all my money in
my business don't get me wrong it's
still a great place for your money and
for your time with your energy but you
gotta take a piece of what you earn and
you gotta bet on some other
entrepreneurs and get outside yourself
specifically and if you look at you know
somebody like warren buffett will tell
you you know look he said my all my
wealth is a result of a couple things
some good genes and compound interest
and living in america so if all you do
is get compound interest on your side
the game changes you know if you take a
19 year old kid
that's got a little job and you say look
i want you it sounds like a lot but i
want to put aside 300 a month let me
show you why 300 bucks a month set aside
thrown in the market average market
return has been eight percent it's been
10 over 100 years but most recent you
know 30 years eight percent so let's say
you get the average return and it
compounds
that kid who starts at 19 with 300 a
month can stop at 27.
he's only done it for eight years never
put another dime in
and he's only put in 24 or 28 thousand
dollars
but that'll grow to 1.8 million without
putting another diamond that's the power
of compounding 28 grand 1.8 million
if his best friend starts at 27 when he
quits and invests every single year all
the way to 65 and he puts in the same
300 a month he puts in 140 grand and at
that time he's got 400 000 less money
so it's not the amount of money it's the
amount of time
time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're gonna win and
you need to get in the game now not wait
till your business is successful my very
first teacher was a man named jim rohn
and he was a personal development
speaker and he had this three and a half
hour seminar he would do that i went to
when i was 17 years old i was already
reading books i was obsessed with
wanting answers i want to know what made
the difference in the quality of
people's lives not because i was
intellectually interested but because i
grew up in a really tough environment i
had four different fathers there was a
lot of my mom was a great human being
who loved me dearly but she you know
abused both alcohol and prescription
drugs so she was very physically abusive
and i was believe it or not 5-1 in high
school i was a little guy so i got the
you know what beat out of me pretty
regularly for things that i didn't do
anything to do with and so it made me
try to figure out what made her work
what makes life work made me more of a
practical psychologist and the modeling
concept came because jim rohn used to
have this phrase he said success leaves
clues
he said if if there's anything you want
in your life don't assume that somebody
has some special gift they may have a
gift but they probably developed it most
of it and if you sow the same seeds
you'll reap the same reward so figure
out what this person's doing different
than anyone else and do that he used to
have a funny way of describing he used
to say tony find out what poor people
read and don't read it
it's like because he said that's the
fabric they're trying to build their
mind from find out somebody who's
successful wealthy not just financially
wealthy but somebody who's rich
emotionally and spiritually and
physically and financially and find out
how do they live their life differently
what are the things they believe what
are they what are some of the daily
disciplines that they're a part of and
so really early on i got obsessive about
wanting to have all the answers so i
said i'm gonna read a book a day because
i figured you know a person takes 10 15
years of their life they pour two or
three four years into this book and you
absorb in a few hours literally a
decade's worth of life experience and
i'm into compressing time so i didn't
read a book a day but i read 700 books
in the area of human development
psychology physiology all of my first
real seven years of reading right my
youth in high school i was mr solution
you have a problem i have a solution
especially if you're a girl i was
especially motivated i could really help
you with your boyfriend understanding
the life cycles of humanity there's a
book called generations it's a big book
it's i think a thousand pages eight
hundred pages bigger than this book
uh but it's a book worth meaning because
it shows you how
as
every hundred years eight hundred years
we went through the same cycles like
what we've just gone through
economically in 2008 happened 80 years
before
and you can go to a thousand years of
roman history and you see it and when
you begin to be able to anticipate
what's coming you know how to take
advantage of the season some people
freeze the death in the winter people
that are prepared might snowboard or ski
and have a good time so uh it's a
brilliant book and it's by strauss and
how it's working the goal if you own a
business and i would assume a lot of
your viewers are business owners are
getting started in business
no matter how good you are in business
think about this
the one universal rule that idiots in
finance know is diversification it's the
only free lunch you've got to diversify
because if you put all your eggs in one
basket no matter how good the basket is
one day that real estate market that
stock market that bond market that
collectibles market whatever you invest
in
radel you showed me statistically it'll
drop 50 to 70 percent on a day
now if you're later in life when that
happens it's over for you right so you
have to diversify and yet most people
they know real estate so they do it or
they know stocks they do it or they grew
up with their hand their parents
flipping things and it's the wrong thing
to do so you've got to diversify in
order for you to be able to truly
succeed and that's why when you own a
business yeah if you put all your money
in your business which is what most of
us do naturally you see a lot of risk
yeah
you put all your eggs in one basket and
there's things that can happen i mean
you know you're let's say you spent 20
years and you figured out how to put
together the ultimate map you know and
remember garmin came out with this thing
called the tomtom i don't remember you
used to put on your are you old enough
to remember that you could put it on
your phone yeah or you just put on your
dash
cost a hundred bucks it was a
breakthrough
they were making like 100 million or
something or yeah yeah six months later
what happened
the iphone came out without google maps
these little bastards this is my friend
came out with it put google maps put
their own map on here and guess how much
zero what's it gonna do your business
when someone takes your product reserve
and gives away for free so i always tell
people competition happens technology
happens what you must do is have a
second business with no with no moving
parts no people
no time maybe it takes you
two to three days a year for two or
three hours after you've read the book
you put it in place and you measure it
two or three times a year that's it yeah
go on with your life now if there's a
trouble in your business you're
financially set i in my life
at 31 companies now we have you know
what we have 1200 employees
seven different industries we do five
billion in sales i mean that used to be
you know me and my seminar business it's
grown geometrically but with all those
moving parts the only way i've been able
to succeed is because i've taken every
one of those businesses i've diversified
my assets so that when things were in
trouble
i still have enough economics to take
care of myself and keep the business
going so everybody needs to create a
money machine that works while you sleep
that doesn't have moving parts and
that's what this is really about money
makes you more of what you are if you if
you're mean you got more to be mean with
if you're you know giving as you are and
your team is you're gonna have more to
give with so i think it just magnifies
it doesn't change anybody but it
magnifies it and i think most of us have
so much emotion tied up around money
because we associate emotions that are
more important to us like freedom to
that or security and when you get to it
also people don't like to compare around
that area so what i try to do when i in
this latest work i did with my book
money master the game was to show people
how to master money instead of being
mastered by it because you either master
who masters you and and trying to
pretend it doesn't matter in the world
we live it doesn't make sense the real
secret is find a way to add more value
to other people than any other human
being in your industry in your category
and if you do that you won't have to
worry about money whatsoever so is there
something small
you've done you know an example was
giving money to you know that child was
a great example of that but there's
something recently you've done that's so
small that you're like really proud of
you know
a lot of people don't think proud is a
good term i think it actually is
um ego is edging god out that's when you
make [__] up to make yourself feel good
but i think if you've really done
something you know you have and no one
could take that from me and so i'm proud
of who i am as a man i'm proud of the
things that you know what goes on when
the camera's not on and there are people
around me all the time that will tell
the people stories about what i'm really
like so i don't have to communicate that
to people i get shared so um i don't
know i don't know there's there's so
many things in life i don't measure them
as big versus small sure my my wife
was somebody who would see one person
and be thrilled and i had to see you
know ten thousand i think so she's
balanced it out for me i still
i feel like life is short and while
you're here i wanna have the most impact
that i can so i go deep and i go wide um
but every interaction to me is an
important interaction and and sometimes
that interaction is just being kind i
know it sounds stupid but kindness can
to the right place at the right time you
know somebody could be suicidal you
don't know you're being kind and
changing their state yeah there's a it's
an interesting story of um there's a
gentleman who who wanted to kill uh
nixon
and he couldn't get access to nixon his
true story and so he became he wrote a
journal that's how we know the details
of it and he decided he's going to go
after wallace and go shoot wallace and
he actually did do that shooting
and when they read his journal it was
fascinating he didn't want to kill nixon
because he didn't like him or wallace he
just want to be famous he wanted to be
worth something
and one of the reasons he didn't tell
nixon is he was going after nixon and he
was this far from the president and old
woman bumped into him just as he's
reaching his pocket to get this gun
and in the middle of this everything's
frenzy he wants a shoe to become the
most famous man you know another one of
those assassins and this woman grabbed
his hand and said i'm so sorry i'm just
so sorry
and he said in his journal afterwards
his hand was on the gun wow and her
looking at his eyes with this love in
her eyes and this kindness in her eyes
he said i couldn't make her witness that
and he put the gun away oh man that
saved nixon's life
right soon after walls you know but
that's the power of a moment of kindness
so i think we underestimate uh you know
somebody came and fed my family was 11
years old you know um obviously the
person must not be alive still because
i've told the story i haven't reached
out to you man reached out to me yeah
but i mean imagine what the impact of
that was by that one little act of
kindness if you look at what makes
people happy it's really two things it's
progress like even you achieve your
goals and oftentimes people achieve a
goal and then go is this all there is
it's because it didn't meet their deeper
needs our need is to keep growing you
know business is growing or it's dying a
relationship's growing or it's dying so
if you're feeling like you're not even
there but you're making progress it
feels alive because we all grow or die
and then when you make progress when you
grow you got something to give
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there